holidays here are supposed to be about
all this relaxing forgetting your cares
and soaking up
a bit of spanish sun but now there's
also a shadow
linda and her daughter georgia have been
part of family holidays to marbella for
many years but now
this one's not quite as carefree they
worry about the quarantine
that will await them when they return to
britain at the weekend linda is a
company director
we've recently started to reopen so we
can all work together again it's been
working so well
uh within the restrictions and there are
25 people
working at the company that i'm a part
of so
it affects everybody if i'm not there i
i'd like to think that we'd be able to
get a test that would
allow us to then go in or it's
incredibly difficult because how are the
government going to keep track of us
do we really have to quarantine if we
know that we're well
georgia recently started her own
business printing suites
she says she can't afford another two
weeks away from work
my business would just completely halt
for that time because
any any orders anything that i might get
in actually can't be processed
or completed until i can be in that
store
there was irritation among the people we
spoke to
about the disruption but also about the
abrupt way they found out
people have been on holiday now for a
couple of weeks um
booked holidays because there was a free
travel
with no quarantine and then with five
hours notice the government say
there's a two week quarantine
there are those who told me they doubted
anyone would check
whether they were actually going into
quarantine some expect the rules to be
dropped
many gather at this beachfront
restaurant to eat and chat
the manager has seen nerves rapidly
beginning to fray
it's just the usual a big change happens
and it's chaos and there's no detail
with it
and no criteria and people react on that
maybe if there was a bit more
information released alongside these
huge changes people wouldn't that we
wouldn't get this knee-jerk reaction
move away from the beaches and you find
this
an eerie emptiness this is 24
hour square it's a massive bars and
clubs aimed
at british tourists and locals say that
now the end of a long
hot day this place should be bustling
but instead
look at it there's no holiday maker to
be seen there's only one bar that's
actually open
and there's nobody inside it what's
clear is that while
some british people here are working out
how to manage the effects of quarantine
plenty of others have just decided to
cancel their holidays altogether
this sorry square is a symbol of how
this virus
is reasserting itself with tourists
going home
and economies being wrecked again
adam parsons sky news